good morning Hank it's Monday I only get
to say that once a year it must be pizza
mess once a year for two weeks we make
videos back and forth to each other
every weekday just like it was 2007 it's
the third most important holiday in
nerdfighteria it's a celebration of love
and pizza and most of all ecommerce one
other thing is you may be able to hear
I'm sick I have a fever I I am out of
bed for the first time in four days
which is good but I'm not feeling great
plus things are terrible just in general
I'm sorry about how terrible things are
this year all our profits and royalties
from Pizza mmus will go to the
foundation to decrease worldsuck and
then be used as matching funds during
the project for awesome so you can know
that your money is being used well and
charitably to decrease worldsuck
what did WH Auden say all I have is a
voice to undo the folded Live Well all I
have is a box full of weird pizza Mis
stuff from dftba.com it's time for an
unboxing video hold on I got open this
thing oh no oh oh god Hank something
terrible has happened something
extremely terrible you know there are
some people who can pull off a mustache
and I am one of them all right I just
gotta open this box I've got a very
sophisticated box cutter it's a plug
first we've got this shirt from Sophia
Cardone abstract Pizza John
oh that's very artistic then there's
this shirt from designer and EJ Pizza
it's mr. potato man peace sign Pizza
John
Maria wind designed this one oh my god
it's epic oh-ho-ho this one's from David
Pemberton there's pizza in his hair oh
my gosh guys guys look at that I these
are I have to put all of these on I mean
why buy one when you can comfortably
wear five Pizza John t-shirts at a time
okay I think this is our last shirt it
was designed by the folks at dftba.com
and it is so cool an extremely subtle
pizza John for those of you who you know
you're proud of pizza miss but not too
proud what else do we have we have a
pizza miss sleep mask all of this by the
way is only available during pizza miss
and then it will disappear forever
dftba.com just because I'm not making
the royalties doesn't mean I'm not
working hard on the sales I think I want
to put on my glasses yeah they could
look better with glasses on oh that's
the business and then there's this
magnificent Pizza John flag for all of
your pizza
John flag needs I'm very excited about
this year's Pizza John calendar which
contains lots of amazing Pizza artwork
from nerdfighters around the world it's
Jay it's magnificent every month hey say
hello to the pizza John satin jacket you
can look like My Little League coach in
1985 made me an alternate on the
all-star team you know farmer Jane's
soap the goat milk soap company my mom
founded oh yeah
we've got Pizza myth soap made by hand
with real goat's milk in Western North
Carolina it's good soap we also have
this don't talk to me before I've had my
pizza Pizza John coffee mug there's a
travel pillow and a paint-by-numbers
Pizza John shirt that comes in a box
with markers and you make your own dang
shirt oh god I love pizza mess I started
out this video so sad and feeling so
terrible I still feel terrible so pizza
miss can't cure disease but it can
clothe you and clean you and provide you
with mugs with which to drink coffee it
occurs to me that people who are new to
this channel are like what the hell is
going on and why does that guy have a
mustache
I'll put an explanatory link in the
doobly-doo below where by the way you
can also find a link to all the pizza
miss stuff available only for the next
two weeks again all proceeds go to
charity Hank I will see you tomorrow
yay Oh Sara's home I have to go show her
my mustache it's her favorite thing hi
it's that time of year again huh